cela je vous remercie d'être en direct
sur arte france les deux parties campent
sur leurs positions l'azerbaïdjan
soutenu par la turquie réclame le
retrait des forces arméniennes et
l'arménie elle demande le retrait des
forces turques du haut karabagh jusqu'où
le conflit peut-il aller doit-on
craindre une guerre dans le caucase
bonjour merci de votre invitation
votre question dernière question
interpelle j'espère que ces deux risques
7/3 me sera pas propagé à d'autres
régions de cocasse là il faut savoir
aujourd'hui que la guerre ne se poursuit
que sur le territoire réservé janet
internationalement reconnu est occupé
par l'arménie alors aujourd'hui la
classe et le quercy les combats
poursuivent aujourd'hui c'est que la
proposition azerbaïdjanaise qui
d'ailleurs est a été réitérée hier par
le président accueillait de dire que
l'arménie s'engage à se retirer des
territoires occupés
quand je dis d'un territoire occupé il
ne s'agit pas de uniquement de vote à la
barre parce qu'il faut savoir qu'à part
le haut karabagh il ya une autre partie
de l'argent qui est occupé par l'arménie
donc là où il ya il n'y avait pas de
minorité arméniens de la minorité
arméniens n'était présent que dans le
haut-karabagh la proposition des
présidents alliés est de dire que
l'arménie ne s'engage à se retirer petit
à petit des territoires occupés et
qu'ensuite on ne mette à négocier sur le
statut du karabakh
les stats notre avoir la position arabe
régionale est la suivante et elle a été
le cas deux n'était pas rare de dire que
l'azerbaïdjan n'est prête à reconnaître
au haut karabagh le l'automobile de plus
importante qui n'existe pas dans le en
pratique et que le haut karabagh soit
resté dans la souveraineté norvégienne
cette proposition d'ailleurs si la
guerre s'est éclaté c'est que depuis les
dernières années
les pourparlers étaient gelés et que
nouveau président arménien dès qu'il est
arrivé au pouvoir il n'a pas vraiment
manifesté de volonté pour poursuivre les
pourparlers qui était engagé auparavant
ce qui est aussi un enjeu en nommer les
choses et ce qui a fait qu'ils la guerre
aujourd'hui on est arrivé là donc
aujourd'hui c'est la région se voient
contraintes de recours à la force et de
libérer les territoires occupés par la
force c'est qu'il n'y a aucun moyen de
discuter avec monsieur pashinian avec
son gouvernement
en tout cas c'est le gouvernement ok
aujourd'hui au pouvoir mais voilà des
conditions justement qui sont posées par
les deux parties on a vu des appels au
cessez le feu se multiplier ces derniers
jours est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que la communauté internationale est
dépassé par un par ce conflit puisque
jusqu'à maintenant que ce soit la france
ou d'autres pays encore personne ne veut
mettre un terme à ces hostilités
je constate avec un grand degré que si
la guerre est devenue aujourd'hui un
inévitable parce que justement la
communauté internationale n'a pas fait
ce que leur dû faire depuis dans ces
temps le groupe de minsk qui est chargée
de cette question
cela fait 27 ans que ce groupe n'a pas
vraiment enregistré des progrès
aujourd'hui je pense que appelé au
cessez le feu
c'est naturel et c'est humain mais
personne aujourd'hui j'ai entendu aucun
responsable pour le meetic de
s'interroger sur le rôle de ce groupe
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait exactement quel
est le progrès parce que là vous dites
est ce qu'on a une chance que ça termine
à lesquelles son sang versé le sang mais
on a eu une chance pendant 27 ans on a
raté cette science c'est dommage
la guerre aujourd'hui n'aurait pas dû
avoir lieu les victimes des deux côtés
que ce soit arméniens d'azerbaïdjan à ce
gâchis ces deux en pertinence et les
gens civile
même les soldats les militaires c'est
des gens jeunes donc ça n'a aucun sens
pendant cinq années le monde entier qui
a été engagée dans le dans le règlement
de ce conflit n'a vraiment rien fait
aucune aucun aucun appel au retrait des
troupes des territoires occupés là
j'entends pas le karabagh parce que là
car à bord et c'est un statut spécifique
il faut discuter pour pour respecter
l'intérêt de toutes les parties
mais je parle des sites autre mesure où
il n'y avait aucune minorité hasard des
analystes et qui ont été occupées par
par l'arménie pour cela la communauté
internationale a rien fait
malheureusement donc aujourd'hui si on
adhère c'est que justement de la
communauté internationale par le peu du
rôle de la russie est ce que justement
moscou peut voit la règle et réglisse
sanofi écoutez je pense que moscou a
beaucoup fait lorsque pendant des années
lucky au sida et dur fait partie de
groupes de l'uiisc mais après moscou
face à leur refus arménienne de se
retirer des régions occupées par sans
qu'on puisse discuter de ce statut haut
karabagh crépitèrent moscou il ne peut
pas intervenir sur le territoire
azerbaïdjanais pour libérer ses
territoires qui sont occupées par par
l'arménie mais politiquement
diplomatiquement
je pense que les autorités russes ils
ont fait tout dans l'or dans le christ
qui sont dans leurs possibilités mais
malheureusement si un pays
le pays qui contrôlent des territoires
occupés refuse de s'asseoir dans la
table des négociations
là on peut constater que les
négociations sont bloquées et qui a plus
rien à faire même que ce soit dans
moscou où d'autres pays merci beaucoup
dib a dit gasol à savoir répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en droit international
spécialiste du caucase